[Music]
thank you so much for joining i'm really
excited to to talk to you about this
because what i was saying during my
intro was that this film is a feel-good
film which sometimes people get give
kind of a short shrift to but you have
two of the world's leading actresses
that ever existed in this film and
what's wrong what's
what's wrong if you walk away from a
film feeling good i don't know don't you
think people seem to want something to
complain about whatever it is how dare
you make me feel good
how dare you make me cry how dare you
make me laugh don't make me feel
anything about something yeah
um so this is adapted from a novella of
the same name um from night the late
1950s
how and and you uh co-adapted this into
the screenplay
how did you come across the source
material and what was it about it that
made you want to make it and leave it in
this time period
lots of good questions in that one
question actually
first of all i have been a lifelong poor
galaco fan so my introduction to him
was through a children's book called
jenny
and i read many of his books but i
missed the mrs harris series
when i signed with a manager in la he
also it happens manage the poor galacto
estate
and so he's the one who first alerted me
to this title and
i read it and i had an immediate
response to it on a couple of levels
first of all
the character is just so delightful and
irresistible and in you know you you
can't but fall in love with her
and want to tell her story
and i have a bit of a thing for
underdogs as well so
she certainly fitted that mold
but secondly my father moved to paris
when i was seven years old so
i've spent quite a bit of my life
between london and paris and i felt that
i could really do justice to both worlds
and that was a very important aspect of
of making the film
um there was another question in your
question there that i wanted to answer
i'm trying to think what it was uh why
did you want to keep it in this time
period that's what it was yeah
we i thought about updating it um and
maybe having it about a filipino made or
something like that which would make
sense and there's a validity to that
but
um
the world of fashion is completely
different now to what it was in the
1950s
first of all it's ubiquitous the idea
that you would have to travel to another
country to buy a dress is is
impossible absurd not necessary
um
and secondly dior which is such an
important character in the film the
house of dior
was truly king in the 1950s in a way
that it never has been again
and
right now
we could probably name five ten brands
that are
the big fashion brands but there isn't
any one amongst them where you can say
this is this is the brand
whereas it was absolutely the case in in
the 50s that dior was
the brand and so that was i think very
important as well
but yeah too many things about
um the ubiquity of fashion and the
specialness the uniqueness of couture at
that time i think is why it had to be
kept to that period as well as
the class differences and the importance
of class many many
aspects of the story you know for
example that
i was under increasing pressure at
various times to cast a younger more
attractive mrs harris because that's
thought to be more commercial
but the story would have been utterly
spoiled if it wasn't about
a woman at that stage in her life so
there are many reasons why i think it
had to one had to respect the original
time and and age of the character
so yeah let's let's talk about your
actors um
what
made you
you know go with these two like
incredible powerhouses who when i watch
this i just
they make it look so easy
they
just they're so magnificent they just
bring all of themselves to everything
that they do
yes and they have extremely different
energies and very different approaches
to how they go about their work which
was really fascinating
and as a director you're always having
to adjust what you do to the individual
talent
so
this was actually a very very difficult
role to cast because
it's a leading role
but it requires a character actor and
there are very very few character actors
who can actually carry a movie
let alone
raise the finance for a movie
so to find somebody
who had those qualities is really only a
handful
and i'd always had my eye on leslie
because i thought she was very right for
this part and when she was nominated for
an oscar for phantom thread i thought
right well now's my chance
but even then i was told that it would
be difficult to finance it with her name
alone
um she has never actually been the sole
star of a film before so um
well since then she made that well no
she did um
ordinary love with liam neeson but i
mean that was the combination of the two
so for it to be her as the person
carrying it that was
it's her first time really
and so
um very luckily for me early on in the
process i had a producer called philippe
carcasson who produced coco before
chanel and more recently the father
and he has a long-standing relationship
with isabel and um he was six degrees of
separation you utilize it's who you know
everybody knows that about this business
so he spoke to her first of all
and she said you know
it's
i like like the script it's very
charming um but i need to meet the
director and i need to
find out who's playing mrs harris so she
leslie hadn't been cast at that point
and i met with isabelle and of course
when we and we got along very well and
we we clicked straight away
and
when uh we cast leslie that was the kind
of final yes if you like because
um paul thomas anderson is a huge
auteur director very revered and
respected in france and of course
isabelle
um had massive respect for
for leslie's work in phantom thread
well
leslie is known for playing it's it's so
interesting that you cast her in this
because i mean i saw her in la a few
years ago here
in long day's journey and tonight
which is one of the most difficult roles
for
for
women in the american theater is that
role
and i was awestruck so if you ever get
the chance to see leslie manville on
stage
it's really special
um
i don't know if i would have thought of
her for this but as soon as i you know
it came up and she was i was like she's
perfect for this
did you ever see mum the series the bbc
series i don't think so no anyone seen
it
yeah
so um it's a really fabulous series you
should try and get your hands on it and
she plays this
very quiet slightly put upon um
working-class-ish
matriarch who's lost her husband
and there are some parallels to mrs
harris but she's a very very kind
character mrs harris has a lot more
get up and go about her and she grows in
stature and confidence
with mum you never see her get angry you
never see her rail against the
appallingness of her family but there
was enough
in that character combined with the
astonishing performance in phantom that
i just knew that she was she was going
to be extraordinary for this did she go
back and look at any of her michael
movies when you were deciding absolutely
i mean i i
i really i first noticed her in another
year
um because that was an extraordinary
performance as well
um
and uh
and i
alan rickman was a dear friend of mine
and i and he they had worked together
she was in the original dangerous
liaisons uh on stage with him oh wow um
playing the um thurman character there's
an irony there which i won't go into now
um
but um
yeah so they he he was also very much in
favor and
and his widow in fact is the one who
said to leslie look um this director is
interested in you for this part you
should take it seriously it's really
going to be a good thing for you so
he became a sort of absent fairy
godfather if you like to the project
i also loved everybody that you had
that's that's in her world you know in
her world in england her friend vi
can you talk about finding a person to
play her best friend vai
yeah i mean this was one of the one of
the things i wanted to do so even though
i set it in its period i wanted it to
feel a little bit fresher and more
contemporary
and the character as written is just a
cockney cleaner like like ada
um
i think there was a danger
if everyone in her world was like her of
of of it being a bit
uh maybe a bit dull a bit cozy so
we
uh took advantage of the fact that in
the 50s there was a big
uh migration from jamaica to the uk
people seeking employment and a better
life
they're called the windrush generation
named after the boat that brought them
over
and so there was a great opportunity to
cast a jamaican actress as the best
friend um historically accurate but
feeling more contemporary as a as an
idea
and um ellen is just the most joyful
beautiful human being
and they have such a natural
they had a great natural affinity you
felt their friendship so strongly uh
straight away
and they're so different um and i just
love those contrasts and then archie
who again could have been a cockney was
was irish so that was a different flavor
again
um and then we had the jamaican bus
conductor
who comes back at the very end as a
possible love interest for advice so we
we were able to
make the world of mrs harris a bit more
diverse and a bit more interesting
i have a trivia question for you i
forgot i wrote this down
uh paul gallico
has had uh i mean i'm sure several but
another
very famous
screenwriter adapt him
into a film do you know who that was
are you talking about the poseidon
adventure
no this is pride of the yankees do you
know what what
screenwriter co-adapted
this was new to me i didn't i i didn't
realize i mean they just have this weird
feeling
gore vidal or somebody like it's herman
mankowitz oh wow i have no idea herman
makowitz co-wrote pride of the year no
idea also known as the lou gehrig's
story okay i'm not a baseball guy you're
in good company
as for people who have uh adapted we'll
know that now galico scripts yeah
um it's a good trivia question
i also wrote citizen kane just for
reference um
so
did you
talk can you talk about the look of the
film because sometimes you know i was
watching it and i was like this
feels like it came out of
i'm looking at something that was came
out of a magazine from this time period
was that something purposeful that you
decided to do with your designers and
your dp
so
the look of the film um had to achieve a
few different things first of all very
clearly differentiate between the two
worlds so i wanted london to feel very
different from paris
and we did that through
uh primarily through a choice of color
palette
so london
was mostly grays and greens and browns
and soft colors like that
and fog etc
and paris was sharper more defined so it
was black and white and more primary and
more punchy colors and we we accentuated
that with the grading as well to create
these two different worlds
i also
hired
one of my dear friends and one of the
most incredible production designers
that's ever lived luciana rigi to do the
production design
because like me she has lived in london
and paris and so she really understood
those two worlds and that was
particularly important because we shot
the majority of the film in budapest for
budget reasons
and also as it weirdly turned out
it had the lowest covert rates in europe
at the time
so we were able to get on with it when
many many productions were stuck
um
and so given that we were in budapest i
needed a production designer who knew
what paris
uh you know a doorknob or a english
window looked like because you know they
we weren't going to find that in
budapest we had to define it
and
in terms of the period feeling
i discussed with the dp the idea that i
wanted it to look a little bit like a
black and white film that had been
colorized
so that was what i was going for
and so we did experiment with starting
with black and white and then adding
color bit by bit the way you would in a
color colorizing process
but the other big decision was after
doing camera tests
it was very very clear to me that the
anamorphic lenses
which were made by cook in the 1950s
which had now been modernized
created a magical feeling by slightly
distorting the edge of the frame
and also changing
what would have been a round
light into a slightly oblong light and i
know that sounds
weirdly particular
but it adds to the sense that you're not
in the real world you are in some kind
of magical that's amazing
that's specificity
yeah wow yeah so that was super
important because the film is an
absolute tight rope between
reality and magic
and if you go too far into the magic
you lose your grip on reality and if you
go too far into the reality you lose the
magic so
it really was such a careful balancing
act between those two things
that's the thing that i loved about this
film is you know despite its being set
in the late 50s
it it was so easy for me as an audience
remember to
put myself in her to be in her shoes in
a mat because we all do imagine like
what if i got some money what would i do
with it you know what i mean not like
lottery
winner money but you'd like change your
life but something
that you could just splurge
and have a good time with yeah i really
think that's one of the absolutely
universal
aspects of the film because i doubt
there's a single person here who hasn't
aspired to something that seems
unattainable or saved for something that
that you know was really beautiful or
precious or special
and it doesn't have to be a an item of
clothing
um so the the i love the
the the actual dior show that she goes
to are those uh were those real
time period dior dresses
yes so i talked about the magic and
realism so one of the
um
the feat that the um the film dips into
is the real house of duo
and so i wanted to recreate it as
truthfully and accurately as possible so
we had the architectural drawings from
dior in order to recreate the house of
dior the interior exactly as it was and
we also
replicated the dresses because in my
initial
conversation with jenny bevin the
costume designer i said i want you to
out do you order i want you to
you know be inspired by him and create
something even more fantastical and she
said you're absolutely mad you cannot
improve on dior
so um
what ended up happening was very
interesting all of the dresses
except for the three invented dresses
from the book namely
revisant the first dress that she sees
in lady dance
bedroom
uh the green dress venus
and temptation which is the dress the
great dress that she wants those three
dresses are the book dresses
and they were all what i call beven dior
so they were all
enhanced
ideas inspired by dior designs
every other dress that you see is an
exact replica of dior including five
dresses that actually came from the
house of dior
that they had made themselves and they
they're the initial dresses that you see
in the show so the further you go into
the show
the more jenny bevan replicas and then
inspired by dresses you get but it's
very very that sequence is fabulous uh
leslie manville's clothes and it are
gorgeous
um
i mean everybody looks
so fantastic in it
it's so funny because i'm not a big
fashion person who like keeps up with
with modern couture but i'm obsessed
with fashion documentaries
and this was like watching a fashion
documentary it was just like the
opportunity to see gorgeous clothes on
amazing people yeah i mean we studied
those youtube documentaries about the
fashion shows and how the models walked
and the circuit that they made from
their dressing room into the salon
out in front of the staircase where the
journalists were sitting and then back
to their
either back through the room or straight
back to if they had a quick change to
make back to the dressing room and we
ran the show
as if it were a real show
and so we determined the sequence and
the sequence was based on
day wear and then cocktail dresses and
then evening wear ball gowns
and finally the wedding dress which was
the traditional ending of a show so
christian dior today
with their archivists and their
historians and their immense pride in
their heritage
have huge admiration and pride for the
film because it was extremely respectful
indeed a love letter to the house of
duel
so i watched an interview with leslie
manville today and um
she had some really nice things to say
about you so you should check it out
it's on youtube yes please she loved
working with you oh thank you
but she also
the interviewer asked her
what she what she hoped people would
take away from this phone what she hoped
they would feel and she said joy what is
it you hope that people will take away
from the film
um there are a couple of things i think
for me one is
a really central theme of my life which
is to never give up on your dreams
um
i don't think any you can have a
filmmaker in the world who
who isn't
completely dogged and persistent because
it's a very hard job to do and you
are often discouraged and think that
you're never going to get there and um
of course if if you do
bail you're not going to get there so uh
persistence and never giving up on your
dreams is very important for me and i
think for everyone and i i feel for
people who
who don't have the courage to continue
uh to pursue what they what they what
they desire and what they dream of so
that's one message
but also i think central to the film and
what attracted me to the characters is
the i think the whole notion of karma is
very central to the film
and the idea that
if you treat people with kindness you
will receive kindness back
um if you behave badly like lady dan
does eventually you will get your
comeuppance and you will
you will be punished
and that may be a bit pollyannaish and
idealistic of me but i think there's
enough truth in it that i'm i'm sticking
to that and ultimately i also want
people to feel uplifted because we're
going through a very rough
period in in the world right now between
climate change and war and
economic crisis and
if people can have a couple of hours
respite from that and come out of the
cinema feeling
really great joyful that's a wonderful
thing
did you feel great and joyful at the end
i did too
thank you so much for coming it's such a
pleasure to talk to you will we have any
questions from the audience or we don't
do that we don't usually know
thank you guys thank you very much
[Music]
you